[Music]
the Internet has changed the world as we
know it but up until now it has been
search share and shop then along comes
Mark Pincus I kept saying who's like a
mantra I was like I want to be the
biggest macro bet on social gaming I
want to be the one who believes in it
more believes and play more and invest
more in that than anyone else
mark Pincus is big bet turned addictive
games into a multi-billion dollar empire
but success didn't come easily Mark said
something to the effect of you know it's
no fun to come in in the morning when
we're losing or quickly I joke to people
that I was kind of like the 41 year old
pitcher for the Yankees who's still
walking out to the mound I'm 41 and I'm
back to what I was doing when I was 28
the journeyman of internet startups
finally found his perfect pitch the most
popular maker of games on facebook may
raise up to 1 billion dollars in its IPO
isn't it incredible
until the playing field shifted beneath
him we had a period when everything was
going right and there was no reason to
believe it was gonna stop what's
happened has been terrible
I mean their business is essentially
collapsed and in space in a few months
as Zynga hits its 6th year the hard
driving competitive CEO is even more
determined to stay in the game I think
that the truth is written over a long
period of time you know I'm in this for
the long run and I'm looking for other
people who are too
in the Silicon Valley version of mafia
wars Mark Pincus would be the Godfather
Mark Pincus is biggest curse is that
some people in the first one ii don't
like him he moves too fast for many
people he used to have this habit of
life getting up on his chair almost
attacking you with his ideas i was after
this dream of starting an internet
treasure an internet treasure is a
service that you can't remember life
before and you can't imagine life
without Pincus has been treasure hunting
since childhood when games were still
played around his family table in
Chicago's Lincoln Park neighborhood
pincus's mother Donna was an architect
mark was the middle child and also the
only boy so it was rather competitive
between the three of them but he always
did things his own way Pincus described
his father Ted who ran a respected
public relations firm as a rule breaker
I thought the one word that most defined
him was hood spa and the Yiddish
definition basically said a leader and
said someone who you know can change the
rules there's something I got for my
father that if you're gonna do something
really go for it be all-in don't
compromise it's a lesson that has stayed
with him after graduating from
University of Pennsylvania's Wharton
School of Business Pincus worked as a
financial analyst in New York before
going to Harvard for an MBA he moved to
Washington DC and found himself at a
career crossroads I woke up in the
middle of the night is 1994 and I
couldn't sleep keeping him awake was the
introduction of the world's first
internet browser mosaic communications
had just come out and spent the whole
rest of the night writing this essay
about what if the future looks like this
I said what if mosaic communications
displaces Microsoft and becomes the next
major platform for the world Pincus says
that essay earned him an interview with
Fred Wilson a young venture capitalist
looking for ideas
Fred said I'll tell you what if you want
to pursue one of those ideas well loan
you $250,000 for four months so as a
demand note and at that time that was a
really risky thing to do Pincus took the
money and ran with it becoming the
president and CEO of a web startup
called free loader the idea with free
loader was to create a toolbar that
attached your browser that let you
subscribe to any content you liked on
the Internet the content downloaded
while you were sleeping
something Pincus and co-founder Sunil
Paul weren't doing a lot of it was
definitely the hardest in terms of
number of hours that I've ever worked on
on a startup
it was so hard it was unsustainable I
mean you can't work seven days a week
more or less continuously forever so we
had four months to get a product in the
market prove it was viable and raised
venture capital money or bring in enough
revenues to support ourselves but this
was our shot and and we were very aware
of that every day was numbered the
demanding schedule paid off in June 1996
the young entrepreneurs sold free loader
to individual Inc for 38 million dollars
mostly in company stock
according to the Washington Post the
payday for 30 year old Pincus was a
hefty 7.5 million dollars and I said
well so now are you gonna retire I mean
why would you keep working and he said
well why would I retire it's what I do
you know it's Who I am newly partnered
with individual Inc
Pincus packed up and moved the
freeloader team to San Francisco but
their fortunes turned when management
problems tore apart the parent company
and within a year free loader was
finished the CEO left kind of imploded
here's Sunil and I were 28 29 years old
we're the biggest shareholders in this
company and they don't let us pursue our
vision which was the whole reason that
we joined up with the company in the
first place it was painful stagnation
for both of us
[Music]
you
[Music]
with his company freeloaders shut down a
restless and determined Mark Pincus
started a new company called support
comm it was a service that would
remotely diagnose and fix computer
problems so imagine in the middle of the
dot-com and the consumer explosion I'm
building the most boring enterprise
software company you know the world has
ever seen
I couldn't get my venture capitalist
even interested in it they asked me if I
could cut meeting short you know when I
went in to present to them it wasn't
interesting it wasn't my vision of an
internet treasure but it was on the way
Pincus soon clashed with those investors
who forced him to step down as CEO but
he remained chairman of the board I
would say you know as a disrupter if I
disagreed challenged I would challenge
the board the whole company if I believe
that we're going the wrong direction and
I think what I realized from then to now
is that it's not just about being a
strong entrepreneur and a strong product
maker but you have to be a strong CEO
and leader and you have to be a person
that people want to follow the guy
everyone in the valley was following
happened to be a former internet
freeloader Sean Parker Parker had
co-founded
a new startup that was becoming the
hottest network on the Internet Napster
for me was the beginning of the social
web that we are now all using today it's
that four and a half million people are
connected right now and that had meaning
to you because it was the first time
that you looked at your computer and you
looked across the internet at other
people he met someone who agreed cereal
start-up investor and then PayPal
executive Reid Hoffman Mark and I
realized that we had certain kind of
kinship of how we're thinking about the
internet kind of like a power to the
people and the projects the most
interested us were massive scale
we both invested in Friendster without
even knowing it and we started hanging
out and and trading notes Friendster
took off like a rocket millions signed
up for the new social network Pincus
wanted to take it one step further
he teamed up with Paul Martino now
managing director of bullpen capital to
start a social networking site of his
own tribe dotnet mark spotted how
important friends ster was maybe even
before the CEO did I remember the
sentence he said to me says Paul don't
you understand this will change the way
we do everything online I said I think
we're add another one was changing
points with this whole internet world
might be reinvented in social context
local listings in Craigslist but tribe
net wasn't Craigslist or Friendster
among its problems it was overwhelmed by
devotees of Burning Man the annual
festival held in the Nevada desert
Vanessa Gregorio - wrote a profile on
Pincus for Vanity Fair magazine Marquez
is a huge supporter of Burning Man
Burning Man is a very inclusive
community you know it's about like going
to the desert and kind of letting your
inner freak out but I don't think he
really thought that you know that should
cross over necessarily to his business
model but some people were sharing a
little too much you know naked guys were
sending pictures of themselves so I
think he recognized that that didn't
really work tribe dotnet was soon
withering and losing money for Pincus
the party was over Marc said something
to the effect of you know it's no fun to
come in in the morning when we're losing
you know there were other social
networks that launched after us that
were bigger when we saw the number
people online at that point on MySpace
we thought this can't be true
I think we had a lot of self-doubt um
and we couldn't figure out how we got
her so wrong and it was confusing and I
went through lots of questioning it was
his third startup to fall short of his
great expectations Pincus was
disillusioned and rudderless bing gordyn
is a partner with Kleiner Perkins
Caufield & Byers and a single board
member yeah went away kind of exploring
meaning of life and by chance came
across tony robbins message that he took
away was most people give themselves
permission to fail he didn't want to
give himself the right
to fail some of his sound bites still
resonate my head like we can write our
own stories and what story do you want
to write and the whole idea of owning
your own destiny and outcome and not
being a victim no excuses with nothing
but time on his hands
Pincus spent hours playing the online
game Rise of Nations I would go online
to play and within minutes these kids
were attacked me with nuclear missiles
and tanks and I was throwing spears at
them and I was so frustrated I spent
hours and I think it tanked a
relationship my life it was not healthy
but you get it you get like addicted
obsessed and I know you should just put
the game down and I couldn't and he
thought God you know how do I beat these
guys you know I would really pay a lot
of money just to get to the next level
here so that started him thinking about
you know how exactly would money
interact in a normal game the king of
social media then made an announcement
that would change pincus's life we're
here to unveil the next evolution of
Facebook platform any developer
worldwide is going to be able to build
full applications on top of the social
graph inside of the Facebook framework
my first lightbulb moment was then and I
said wow I could offer games as kind of
an always-on way for people to socialize
and I don't have to build a social
network and I'm using poker I have to
admit that I kind of thought he was a
little nuts I wasn't convinced that it
was a genius ideas put it that way
you
for Mark Pincus the fourth attempt at a
tech startup was the charm he had
finally hit on his big idea he named it
after his beloved American Bulldog Zynga
the first hand dealt by the new game
company was a classic Texas Hold'em
we literally wondered is anyone gonna
play we were in the rooms to start with
because we thought they shouldn't be
empty and then we just saw the viral
nature of people inviting each other to
the game take off mark kept going online
and saying oh my god there's a hundred
people playing playing Texas Hold'em and
then it was like a thousand people I
mean it was it just snowball you take
this desire I'd had my whole career to
create something long-term meaningful
that was one of these verbs in our life
and now I had play oh my god play wait
that's as good as search the game was
free revenue came from ads for other
Facebook Applications Pincus moved
urgently to grow the company I kept
saying it was like a mantra is like I
want to be the biggest macro bet on
social gaming I want to be the one who
believes in it more believes in play
more and invest more in that than anyone
else worried his own funds weren't
enough to keep up Pincus looked for
outside investors with a condition I was
very upfront with investors that I was
building this company only for the
long-term we were never gonna sell the
company I was going to be a controlling
shareholder and board member and an
equal partner with my investors John
Doerr is a legendary venture capitalist
with Kleiner Perkins Caufield & Byers
Dorr was interested in Zynga but knew
about pincus's uncompromising reputation
someone was trying to do some checking
on mark and came back with the report
that he wasn't the kind of entrepreneur
that kleiner perkins would back i
smarted off well maybe we better change
what the kind of entrepreneur is who-who
we would back a group of investors led
by kleiner perkins gave the sprouting
Zynga a 20
9 million dollar injection of cash but
Zynga's next hit Mafia Wars came under
attack when the creator of the game mob
wars sued for copyright infringement
Dean Takahashi is lead games writer for
the tech news website
ventureBeat the game design was was very
similar to another mafia game created by
a fellow named Dave my history he you
know rightly pointed out that almost
every aspect of this Zynga game was
similar to something that he had already
done Zynga settled the lawsuit for an
undisclosed amount the accusations
continued when Zynga released farmville
it looked a lot like farm town released
by game company slash key months earlier
Zynga very quickly turned around and
duplicated this game and it got tens of
millions of more users because it had
done the social layer right Pincus
disputed the copycat charge claiming
game mechanics were not copyright
protected and millions of users were
also attracted to another feature of
Zynga games virtual goods he believed
other gamers like him would be willing
to pay to get ahead Doug McMillon covers
Pincus for Bloomberg News and Business
Week in farmville you get your own plot
of land and you can make your own
character and you can buy different
things to put on that farm like a fence
or a cow or a tractor and it's all about
decorating and expressing yourself
ultimately for Zynga the cash cow here
is the items that you can buy to put in
that farm
that cash cow was pushing Zynga into
becoming the biggest online game
operator in the United States but then
pink has faced a new controversy the
Silicon Valley blog TechCrunch released
a 2009 video of Pincus speaking to a
group of budding entrepreneurs so so I
funded the company myself but I did
every horrible thing in the book to just
get rubbish right away Marc's comment
that he did every horrible thing in the
book was probably the biggest mistake
that he's made in his career he kind of
put himself at odds with the whole ethos
of Silicon Valley which is build a great
product first and then figure out how to
make money on it Oh control your justice
you care the whole talk I was really
trying to make a point to them about
consumer Internet companies can have
revenues and be profitable and they're
not just about eyeballs and all the
things that were horrible about the
dot-com bubble I'm sorry I said it
because I think it didn't just throw me
under a bus it through the the
innovation and so much about what
are.what Xing has done under a bus
[Music]
Zynga owed its phenomenal growth in
large part to Facebook which provided
over 90% of its revenue ads for Zynga
were popping up like weeds on Facebook
but not all users wanted to be farmers
or mobsters the non gaming players on
Facebook started complaining saying can
you put a stop to this so Facebook did
in Zynga lost tens of millions of users
Facebook's founder Mark Zuckerberg was
also looking for a bigger cut of the
hundreds of millions of dollars being
hauled in by Zynga money Zynga didn't
want to give up with that much at stake
the standoff turned into a Silicon
Valley version of Mafia Wars kleiner
perkins venture capitalist John Doerr
found himself in the middle there was a
deep disagreement between Facebook and
Zynga and Mark wanted some advice on how
to handle it I went up and met with Mark
and his team and then said well let's
talk to Facebook about this no company
had ever done what Facebook had done
before Facebook was nothing more than an
online click through agreement opened up
their entire network of users to any
company in the world and also no company
had ever done what we had done which is
grow the size business and the size
footprint of users on top of an
agreement like that
the two companies didn't even have a
one-page legal agreement between us
Pincus had more at risk losing Facebook
as a platform could have meant the end
of Zynga I encouraged the two companies
to look for a common ground which they
found and then to sustain their
relationship the two companies faced a
real decision whether or not we were
gonna double down on each other or
diversify away Mark Zuckerberg isn't a
normal CEO and he's really kind of
courageous and visionary we wanted to
make something else work
we both saw that it was in our users
interest to double down together
Zuckerberg and Pincus announced a
five-year strategic relationship
Zynga agreed to a 30 percent tax on
virtual products it sold through
Facebook with a crisis averted
Zynga went on a spending spree in late
2010 they acquired the company new toy
and their words with friends franchise
for fifty three million dollars
by the end of 2011 the company was
getting too big to remain private
just before Zynga's initial public
offering the New York Times reported
that some company employees were
grumbling about the demanding work
environment Pincus had heard it all
before I think Mark doesn't suffer fools
DreamWorks Animation CEO Jeffrey
Katzenberg sits on Zynga's board of
directors and it's as simple as that and
what he has is a very high regard in
admiration for smart talented people who
deliver and if you'd are not that then
he doesn't have a lot of patience so
maybe that's why we're buddies Zynga's
IPO is said to be the biggest u.s. web
one since Google Zynga went public in
December 2011 with a 7 billion dollar
valuation and with Pincus retaining
unprecedented voting power but Pincus
couldn't control what happened next its
first quarter earnings report in 2012
showed that the company was spending
more and more on R&D and spending more
and more for each game that it was
putting out and users were not staying
is in fact it was saying to investors
that a majority of its growth was coming
in mobile games which was not where it
was spending majority of its R&D dollars
the growth on the web slowed down you
know it kind of stalled the transition
to mobile surprised us as it seems to be
surprised in the whole world eight
months after its initial public offering
the company had lost over 70% of its
value and there was more bad news to
come another top executive is leaving
Zynga several key executives left and
the company was hit with lawsuits for
copyright infringement
and insider trading and the fragile
relationship between Facebook and Zynga
showed signs of unraveling its next big
fall came in the wake of Facebook's IPO
bazinga relies almost exclusively on
Facebook for its fourths revenue and
Facebook's IPO was a big fizzle that in
turn dragged Zynga down along with it
Zynga just cut its earnings forecast for
both the third quarter and the full-year
quote the third quarter of 2012
continued to be challenging and while
many of our games performed as planned
as a whole we did not execute to our
satisfaction end quote
despite the stunning decline Pincus
DoubleDown announcing plans for new
games a focus on mobile and a move into
real money gaming he and his wife
Allison live on San Francisco's gold
coast with their twin daughters Allison
is also a successful entrepreneur who
runs a high-end home decor website Marc
always had a passion he always wanted to
be like Google now and Amazon and I
think for mark it's very important that
Zynga is right up there with all of them
I think that the truth is written over a
long period of time you know I'm in this
for the long run and I'm looking for
other people who are too
[Music]